hi
i'm aaron from the canvas team i'd like
to talk to you about the canvas 2d api
the friendly graphics api that's been
there all along
its beauty its brilliance and all the
incredible stuff we've been working on
from an extremely unbiased point of view
first let's start off with a love story
rhonda was a rectangle
a rounded rectangle she loved being a
rounded rectangle
it excited her to deliver messages she
adored being a button
one day she even got to be a guitar pick
shaped profile photo for a music startup
rondo was too busy to think about love
she enjoyed doing so many things
together with her current implementation
css however sometimes css
just wasn't the right partner for the
things ronda wanted to do
she longed for the romance of javascript
to respond to user interactions
to dance around the page light as a
feather
her good old friend canvas 2d was always
around
but sometimes she felt like they didn't
quite understand one another
then one day she met webgl they hit it
off
she became a real 3d mesh camera
lighting
shaders but it was all so much work
even the simplest things became
herculean efforts that required
coordination and lots
and lots of code and now she couldn't
even run on certain devices
finally one day rhonda's good old friend
canvas 2d showed her what they'd been
working on
a lightweight round wrecked
implementation now
rhonda could fly about the page spinning
twirling
scaling and changing looks with just a
single line of code
her new implementation was so beautiful
so simple so
lightweight and fun she nestled up to
her new bow and said
it's always been you canvas 2d
thank you all for indulging me in that
romantic comedy about a shape
for uh some reason my scriptwriting
career never took off
what's important is that your good old
friend canvas 2d
has been working on improving themselves
and now might be worth another look
canvas 2d has been around since uh
since forever well forever in internet
years
the oldest spec i could find was from
2005 so
the chrome t-rex roamed the earth
well not the chrome t-rex wasn't even
around then either
it's supported in firefox chrome safari
opera edge conqueror vivaldi brave sea
monkey double falcon electrode
charmander and kadabra
and of course the astute among you will
mark when i stopped naming obscure web
browsers
and started naming pokemon canvas 2d
is available on devices from car
consoles to refrigerators to
playstations
it's even available in space
really spacex's dragon capsules
interface
is rendered using chromium and
javascript the point is
it's everywhere it's everywhere
35 of web pages have a canvas element
and 98
of canvas elements use the canvas 2d
rendering context
if you're already using canvas 2d i'm
excited to show you new features that my
team has been working on
if not i want to open your eyes to the
beautiful world
of canvas 2d because it's just the best
and easiest way to do certain things in
a browser
how else would you get the expression of
drawing apps the power of cells and
equations in google sheets
the key visualization of bloomberg
terminals or of in-browser medical
imaging
or the simple fun of browser games
alas there's still some developers who
don't use canvas
why so here are some reasons we hear
svg and css and the dom can do
everything canvas can do and more
which is fair but sometimes don't you
want a programmatic interface with all
the power that that brings
also we're focusing on the and more part
and bringing
to canvas some of the more popular
features of these other technologies
we're showing canvas some love second
thing people say is
it's so hard we understand
certain things have been hard to do in
canvas 2d but it's getting easier
we've listened to developers and we know
that ergonomics is important
canvas loves you finally people say we
can't use canvas for our web app we need
performance well
to them i say canvas is performant also
it's getting more performant
if you're thinking of performance
remember yes we can this
anyhow none of these reasons are good
use canvas everywhere
well not everywhere we don't want to
propose canvas as a replacement for the
dom
just as a good alternative when you want
lower level graphical control
but you should use it in more places
than you're used to
because canvas is getting better we're
addressing the concerns i outlined and
implementing new features
for the canvas 2d api these features are
currently live in chrome
and can be used by enabling the
experimental canvas 2d api features flag
in chrome flags
and they're coming to other browsers
soon
so part 1 showing canvas some love
we're working on catching up to css
we've been paying attention to the most
common requests from developers
for missing features and have added a
few here which i will
now describe the first is conic gradient
you've seen linear gradients you've seen
radial gradients
how about a nice conic gradient your
color pickers
need not be static images no longer
the most common feature request we get
by far is to improve text rendering
in canvas and we're working on it with a
new api
we've added a bunch of new attributes to
canvas text
like text letter spacing
text word spacing font variants
for all the typographical geeks out
there kerning who doesn't love kerning
font stretch text decoration
underline position and finally text
rendering
that's a whole lot of textually explicit
content
perspective transforms canvas 2d
is of course 2d it's right there in the
name but what if i told you
canvas 2d could be 3d
introducing canvas 2.5 d
but it's actually just canvas 2d
but we have added non-athline transforms
which is
a fancy way of saying we support the 4x4
matrices
that css has for a long time
of course i've already mentioned the
famous
the groundbreaking the world-changing
rounded rectangles they're used all over
the place
and used to be surprisingly difficult to
draw
was once serious path jiu-jitsu is now
just a single draw call
part 2 ergonomics canvas loves you
we want canvas 2d to be as easy for
developers to use as possible
though it's great already there are a
couple of areas where we collected the
most common usage patterns and try to
add simple
built-in functionality without further
ado
i present to you what was once the
canonical way to clear a canvas
and we've been living with this it makes
no sense
i feel like i need to personally
apologize but
happily the new api has a reset function
that clears the canvas
resets the path resets the transform and
the transform stack
with just a single call array color
input
setting color values with strings make
sense in css but
animating them in canvas is a pain now
you can pass just an array of numbers
for color
and tweak fade or interpolate them to
your heart's content
we also plan to support color spaces
with this feature though that's still in
the works
svg filters are an amazing extensible
beautiful piece of web graphics that
maybe you didn't even know existed
these filters are already implemented in
canvas 2d and unfortunately the
interface is
difficult to use it's xml strings
and it doesn't work on webworkers but
with the new api there's a programmatic
object-oriented interface for filters
now you can finally use them with ease
last part is performance there's always
room for improvement with performance
as developers performance has been
holding us back from using canvas for
specific use cases but with the new api
i'm here to tell you
yes we can this will read frequently
is an attribute we've added forget image
data which is how you read pixel data
back from the canvas
it can be very slow but it's really
useful for generative effects
the new api gives developers a way of
explicitly marking a canvas for readback
this allows us to optimize things under
the hood and keep canvas
fast for a larger variety of use cases
uh it's been around
in firefox for a while already but we're
finally
making it part of the official spec we
all
hate a sad tab such a sad tab let's make
sad tabs happy again
on low respect devices with a million
apps open it's been possible to run out
of gpu memory or run into some other
kind of dragon
and get your context lost unfortunately
until now there's been no elegant way to
deal with this once the user refocuses
on your page
but with a new api a canvas can notify
the dom
when something has gone wrong and
re-initialize the context automatically
so that's it those are the nine new
features
that are added to canvas we look forward
to seeing what amazing things you all do
with them
we're also always excited to receive
feedback for even more new features
if you have some great ideas whether
you're new to canvas
you've been using it for years or you've
been avoiding using it for years
i'm here to tell you to give canvas
another look it's the api next door
that's been there all along thanks
[Music]
you